how are you
[Applause]
I have been a fan of conan and his pompadour
long before peña grandson
ruined it forever that look is for
me it is really an honor to be here I
love it and I think that in fact camps is the
best thing that has happened to us  because to
begin with, I warned that we Mexicans for
five minutes stop thinking that
we have the worst president in the world
and it also inspired conan to
come to mexico to do a program with
pure mexican talent to show
that we are not thieves that we are not
rapists that  we are not criminals
because I can leave a little bit we live here in
the dressing room
[Applause]
and in fact if with everything that is
happening in the world and with everything
an economic crisis is already felt in the country
I felt it recently when I went to do
a  a show for a company
the company's year-end show better we are
feeling the crisis a lot because last year
's end they closed six
flags for us they took 5,000
people to raffle  This year's cars
raffled off bikes and they brought you
and he didn't, well, yes, he is delighted,
but it really is what they have in crisis
because it is an industry that shouldn't
be in crisis, it is a company that is
dedicated to providing anesthesia for hospitals and
I feel  That's not something you
save money on,
yes, because how
are they going to operate on
you?  a lot has happened and here I
am also seeing it I see botox people bring
the winds don't be fools you
basically are the ones who are like this
but very happy inside then
never
and I know that you can tell from what I
'm saying but it doesn't go away  to note
[Music]
the ones that bring the button so common
I think there is already an excess of botox in
the world I don't bring my friends also
botox the celebrities I went to Los Angeles I
was homeless with botox without a house without
wrinkles
no they don't have no open either
I think people are going to start
hiring other people to
have expressions for them that's going to
do a real job if you're
fighting with your boyfriend and you tell him I
'm super mad at
you I can't show it to
you so maria
jp
I did a real job. In
fact, I want to take advantage of this
example to implore you to stop giving
your children biblical names.
they ask me
hey do you have room for a lot this date
I don't know just jesus a
[Applause]
I love those who try to start the
applause it's like where ready
and another crisis that I see in the world in addition
to all this and in addition to botox that in
fact yes  they know people with botox it
always bothers more because it is not a
disability they decided to be like this
but another crisis that I see I feel that there is
a crisis in love I feel that
men no longer know how to flirt with them  as
women and it is not because they are ugly it is
because of the feminists because there are
feminists there are good magazines but
skip it that when they defend things
that are worthwhile like that they respect
us that they pay us the same as the men who
do not rape us
and then there are the  other feminists
who don't feel for things that aren't
even worth it start like this
happening in front of an obsession it's
because it's not called ox to have
I come here to help them I come
here so they know how to flirt again we have
to go back to  The basics are dangerous,
women, it's very easy, if you're a good
joker, you have 50% of the battle born
of
joker.